The viewDidLoad function
can be very useful for
running code once our ViewController
is loaded in to memory.
What about running some code right
before the view appears on screen?
For that,
there are two functions we can use.
The viewWillAppear and viewDidAppear.
WillAppear happens right before the view
and ViewController appear on screen.
And didAppear gets called
immediately after the view and
ViewController appear on screen.
Remember, that the view and
ViewController are linked.
A UI ViewController and
any subclasses of it have at least one
IBOutlet that always goes to a UI view.
Here, we're going to use auto
complete to help us out.
In the ViewController.swift file move
right to the bottom in the space
directly above the last
closing curly brake.
Start typing viewWill.
You can see Xcode's auto complete
showing us the viewWillAppear function.
It knows that ViewController is
a subclass of UI ViewController.
It also knows in UI ViewController
there's a function you can override
called viewWillAppear.
Clicking on this function
fills it in for us.
Auto complete makes sure
that the function name and
parameters are correct and
that there's no typos.
See the highlighted text
here that says code?
Click on it.
This is where we're
going to type our code.
For now let's add the line,
viewWillAppear called.
If we run this app by pressing the run
button we can see the print statement
being called when our
ViewController appears on screen.
There it is.